[Musik]
ein kleines felsen lässt mit imposanter
burganlage
das ist grün umgeben von den ausläufern
der schweizer alpen
der namen grüne verweist auf das
wappentier der gemeinde den kranich
französisch la grün etwa 2000 menschen
leben hier aber jährlich kommen rund
eine million touristen und den berühmten
käse kennt natürlich jeder kenne ich gut
schmeckt toll den gibt's auch in
brasilien
ich mag vor allem den alten grün wenn
wir zeit haben probieren wir den rund um
den ort grasen kühe der holsteiner rasse
51 alpkäse reihen im kanton stellen den
käse auf ganz traditionelle weise her
auf 1600 metern höhe hat die familie
peter ihre hütte 52 kühe gehören zur
käserei
[Musik]
bild pd arbeitet rund um die uhr an der
käseherstellung in einem großen
kupferkessel beginnt die erste phase
wenn die milch masse dickflüssig ist
rührt er sie immer wieder mit zwei holz
schaufeln durch
der anfang ist am allerwichtigsten bei
der herstellung mit diesen schaufeln
sorgen wir dafür dass sich die masse in
körner scheidet
[Musik]
jetzt steht die geburtsstunde des käses
bevor per hand lässt sich am besten
prüfen welche konsistenz die kammer
haben
für den grünen wird nuru milch verwendet
[Musik]
eine gute qualität
ich kontrolliere das mit der hand wir
haben hier keine technischen apparat um
etwas zu prüfen
wir verlassen uns ganz auf unsere sinne
hier kann man schon fühlen wie weich er
ist
schauen sie wie sich die körner
herauslösen
[Musik]
mehr technik und viele bottiche gibt es
in einer schaukäserei ganz in der nähe
von grün anders als in den alpen reihen
haben hier besucher zutritt und
beobachten die herstellung von oben die
käselaibe reifen bei 13 grad celsius
jeder leib erhält einen stempel der die
herkunft nachweist auf dem käse ist die
nummer der käserei angegeben diese
nummer hier
außerdem findet man die nummer auch auf
der verpackung des grün wer also
beispielsweise den grünen in deutschland
kauft kann im internet die nummer
eingeben und herausfinden aus welcher
käserei dieser käse die man ist
eigentlich stammt
nur die milch von kühen die auf den
wiesen von grüner weiden wird zu den
berühmten käse verarbeitet er wurde
mehrfach als bester hartkäse der welt
ausgezeichnet